é
[Música]
a minha luta é enquanto mulher negra e
longo
trabalhadora rural trabalhadora Urbana
uma vez que a gente vê em vir para
cidade ao menos 13 anos é Mas trabalhei
lá no quilombo né pequenas hortas
comunitárias e nas terras dos imigrantes
alemães né trabalhar em terras que era
dos Quilombolas mas depois foram dadas
com os imigrantes nós somos Imigrantes
também trazido para trabalhar eu sempre
digo nós negros somos matéria-prima
importada para o trabalho né e por isso
que além de falar do trabalho doméstico
eu quis falar sobre a educação essa
educação que foi negada aos negros e
negras as crianças negras dos quilombos
e eu era uma delas então eu vim para a
cidade com 13 anos foi aonde eu fui
começar a estudar no
Alô especial onde eu fui escrever o nome
da minha cidade ela Pelotas e um
bloquinho de material reciclado eu não
consegui colocar Pelotas ali ele faltou
espaço eu queria colocar as letras de
tamanhos que tava no quadro então a por
isso que eu me sinto bem à vontade para
falar sobre essa questão da exclusão do
povo negro convite já é o meu espaço de
falar né falando sobre Meu Povo sobre
mim né II a educação negada é que passa
o que muita muita gente fico para trás e
muitas coisas né hoje quando a gente
fala igualdade é preciso muito da
auto-estima para esse povo com
reconhecimento não sonegar informação e
para nosso povo negro pois estou ligado
foi negado a gente poder estudar né a vó
mãe bisavós tudo pessoal tipo nessa
região e em outras regiões também do
país e do mundo onde eu vou ver o
racismo acentuado nos nossa cidade foi o
último foi a última abolir a escravidão
aí ainda hoje ainda a gente ia
trabalhadoras domésticas trabalhando no
chamado trabalho análogo à escravidão
quer dizer os sonhos trocar a continua e
não é de graça que o atual governo em
alguns muitos aspectos não quer tem a o
curso de história e antropologia essas
ações toda porque não quer que o covão
sabe saiba a história real e nós
enquanto negros e brancos solidária luta
da inclusão da Igualdade nós temos que
tomar força para que isso seja ampliado
esteja estimulado a este povo tem acesso
à informação porque a gente quer
igualdade ou mesmo a primeira mulher
negra tem ajudado a deputada Federal vai
1990 é Deus nos anos 80 tomei
consciência da minha história posso a
minha alma não é branca que quando eu
era empregada doméstica aí me já mas tem
uma negro de alma branca eu ficava
quieta né ou então vamo lá tá na minha
alma não tem cor minha mãe era uma
mulher negra né meu pai era era o
cruzamento de índio o membro meu avô mãe
que meu pai italiano e quando se uniu
com o meu avô bugre não é que era indico
marcando ela foi de verdade porque chega
uma cidade que faça um bom trabalho é
isso considerada negra dá uma branca
outras conversa mulata mulata porque há
pouco tempo e vende abaixa a câmera
Federal e eu vi uma professora falar boa
mulata cruzamento de égua com burro olha
eu fiquei mesmo vou mais a palavra não
dá para gente usar minha mãe era uma
mulher
graça em maiores mundo dela né meu pai
eram uma mistura de italiano um
bugue né acontecesse mas considerava
negro porque também não consegui isto a
minha por isso porque nem eu nem eu
também não né ninguém pode vir estudar
então isso é uma ligação da escolaridade
que teve um povo negro povo misturado
com declarava negro o cabelo enroladinho
lá mais escuro ficou na minha mente
depois que os homens vai passando lá nos
anos 80 quando vem a Campanha da
Fraternidade ouviu o amor desse povo é a
desempenhado pela igreja católica e
rogamos as histórias envolvendo o a
princesa não era tudo os primeiros
indigentes que teve primeiros velhos
ancião na rua foi o povo negro né as
velhos negros né então a gente vê
histórias assim e só um educação hoje
com uma exclusão desses dados que é da
sociologia da antropologia da história e
vai contar isso para o povo aí eu tenho
Ensino Fundamental e hoje eu vejo muitas
vezes que não têm escolaridade para
estar a
e usando o internet com grande potência
a maioria dos trabalhadora doméstica
também não tem i.a. a maioria esmagadora
é a mulher negra da categoria mas eu
escolhi esse falar sobre uma reeducação
porque hoje é preciso
as forças e querem realmente a inclusão
social
EA igualdade nós temos que trabalhar
oportunidade formação a autoestima é
muito valiosas ele tem curso online é
tanto na no apoio psicológico para dar
apoio psicológico sobre saúde para as
trabalhadoras sobre a poderem superar
essa situação de pandemia desemprego
ninguém que foi dispensada as
trabalhadoras de a lista que são
trabalhadoras domésticas que não é outra
categoria diarista doméstica é
trabalhadora doméstica
foram dispensadas então isso mexe muito
com um emocional Quem estava com
carteira assinada recebeu tchau tchau
quem não tava ficou a mexer nesse
auxílio que agora ficou de 150 eu só
queria que o presidente os ministros
deputados Trocasse o salário deles um
mês que você ver com 150 200 cais ou até
mesmo 600 a gente está mudando seja
menos tempo sociais
mas a educação para esse povo que ficou
a caminho e ficou sem auto-estima quando
nossos antepassados pelo fato não
poderia estudar muitos até se acomodar
bom de repente eu mereço isso não ir
para escola mas eu lá fora quando todos
os meus primos e eram Claros cabelo liso
foram para escola só uma que a minha tia
não deixou eu ir para escola que era a
mesma unidade para me acompanhar eu nem
percebi aquilo sabia que a gente era da
lavoura o meu brinquedo foi o
instrumento de trabalho na largura e
depois quando eu vim já as cidades
assumir já ajudar minha mãe a lavar
roupa para fora que elas trabalhadora
doméstica e também e para fora eu
comecei a ajudar e aí confiança carvão
então era uma conclusão que às vezes até
eu queria pagar as pragas soprava acabar
sujando toda roupa tinha que lavar tudo
de novo mas era isso tudo no colégio tu
não lavando roupa e depois já os 14 já
fui trabalhar si mesmo frases de família
para trabalhar cuidar a criança e fazer
todo o serviço da casa e comecei nas 20
anos a conhecer a militância já também
no movimento social criação de
comunidades eclesiais de base Pastoral
da doméstica depois Associação das
trabalhadoras domésticas sindicato
depois Federação Conselho Nacional e vai
essa americanos eu tô daí quando a gente
vai descobrindo a história a gente vai
descobrindo que tem muito chão para
gente caminhar na ajuda do Despertar de
empoderamento das mulheres mas aí quando
eu vou Popular Congresso Nacional em
1989 eu conheci laudelina Campos Melo e
Benedita da Silva bom né E aí depois de
várias histórias que a gente vê enquanto
o rego Anastácia Carolina de Jesus agora
as mulheres negras que para mim foram e
são educadoras mesmo sem ser professoras
quando eu vejo professoras e levam
também despertar e do apoio da gente
seguindo uma caminhada no movimento
social pela educação aí eu sinto a
professora Vera triângulo e para mim
matéria de deslanchar nível Nacional a
minha consciência de Negritude junto com
os agentes pastorais negros professora
Vera Triunfo para mim uma referência
muito grande no Rio Grande do Sul para
mim foi o grande incentivo com
espelhamento o yin poder amento da
transmissão de apoio que me deram essas
mulheres né e outras que e também seguem
a luta que o caso aí a Sandra ali e acho
que foi ela que me indicou para a ser
uma convidada para esse debate que esse
reconhecimento de troca diferentes e as
outras pessoas que se integram na estão
nessa luta aqui sentiu vou levar o
conhecimento as camadas que estão aí
vivendo Resistindo essa exclusão que a
gente tem no Brasil eu fui a três vezes
candidata a vereadora mas a primeira vez
eu fui candidata a deputada Federal
mesmo porque eu sei que é lá em Brasília
e volta uma favor do povo e aqui gostam
contra a população também e que nós
corro excluído o povo empobrecido povo
negros e índios e brancos e daí então
sofremos na carne o
retrocesso político é importante e nos
unamos com todas as forças positivas
hoje aqui mudam e querem realmente a
igualdade de oportunidade para toda a
população porque não é Deus não é só
para um grupo é para todos e a gente
está bem como é que a gente tenta
caminhar tinta trilhar pelos caminhos de
derrota ar tudo impede ovo a viver
melhor de ter uma vida melhor